you'll have sinned a great sin in the
sight of God you are not worthy to
receive these Ten Commandments in 1956
Charlton Heston made Hollywood history
by playing Moses in sessile BD Mills the
Ten Commandments it was DeMille's second
take on the biblical tale 33 years
earlier he released a silent version of
the story of the Hebrew exodus from
Egypt both films were ambitious in their
scope while the 1956 version was
groundbreaking in its use of special
effects the silent film required
thousands of actors crew and animals
along with an immense construction
project DeMille commissioned designer
Paul Ariba known as the father of art
déco to build a lavish set 12 stories
high and 800 feet wide in the guadalupe
Nipomo sand dunes on the california
coast after filming wrapped the set was
too expensive to move and too valuable
to leave for a rival filmmaker to use so
DeMille ordered it buried there was no
such thing as over-the-top for Cecil B
DeMille author Scott Eyman wrote the
DeMille biography Empire of dreams that
generation of filmmakers believed in the
physicality of moody's when if they were
going to do the Civil War they did the
Civil War they got they got a couple
hundred people or a couple thousand
people needed the Civil War
so if DeMille is going to recreate
ancient Egypt he builds it on the same
scale as ancient Egypt was built now
archaeologists have unearthed part of
one of the 21 Spinks is DeMille left
behind this week they discovered a
300-pound head still intact after nearly
a century in the sand given man these
objects have lasted 94 years even though
they were only built to last for two
months during filming
it really speaks to the craftsmanship
and the level of skill that the artisans
who go recovery of these Hollywood
artifacts is a delicate process
unlike the Great Sphinx of Giza which
was carved by the ancient Egyptians out
of bedrock the ones built by arive are
made from plaster of Paris
despite their fragility the statues
recovered this week have a surprising
characteristic though they were set
pieces in a black-and-white film they
were painted they would have used
different pigments on the movie set in
order to create shadows and light and
depth and prevent this very solid look
of one color either black or white so in
the movie these are great Wow what a
production I love this the good news for
wannabe indiana jones' like myself
yes keen to see this magical the Sphinx
heads will be on display Anthony at the
guadalupe dunes starting next year
okay I'm going book your ticket now I
love it when the sets were as epic as
the movie right and then that other
directors might use them so bury them in
the sand for a whole what just a great
story the physicality of movies they
don't make them like they used to sure
don't